I want to mention someone who I believe
we've brought him into the conversation
before but he's one of the unsung heroes
here Eduardo Eduardo yes you do a
wonderful job thank you sir as do you oh
okay you're on thin ice just me Eduardo
oh my God what is your what is your
exact title at work production audio
engineer whatever you want to call it so
Eduardo and I get along fine he's uh
very good at what he does and he he did
a brilliant job uh setting up uh this
new podcast Studio that we have and we
are indebted to you sir but you and I
have run afoul of one another we have
because I guess you're a music fan and
you started uh in my opinion
aggressively choosing the music that
would be playing even before we start
recording so I would come in and uh you
made some strong choices early on I
played some I think you called it
aggressive Jazz when I first I came in
here and it was scooty Jazz you know
scatting Jazz kind of
and I didn't know if you were running an
after hours Club
you offered me a Brandy that's right you
said have a seat Daddy-o sounds pretty
good I underestimated your level of
coolness
you didn't have any blink 187.
why would you do a call back to
something that
we were doing so well I don't think you
know how this works he's going
succession yeah sure people listen
anywho Eduardo I came in and I said
what's with the music and you it's
interesting I think a lot of people in
your position probably at that point
would have killed all music but no you
kept swinging for the fences and every
time I come in there's new genres
playing new tunes and today I came in
you had the killers Blair that's right
which
should I admit that you thought it was
maroon 5. okay
okay not to not to you know throw it
over the bus but you did though
ruin seven I mean I didn't I didn't have
any idea who it was right but I just
said hey what's you know let's count it
with the maroon 5. I wasn't trying to
actually identify them as Maroon 5 but I
think it's just all music in general I'm
not ready to hear music when I come in
here I think that might be it I might
what do you think to be honest I'm
enraged right now and I'm gonna tell you
why it's because earlier you guys were
having an exchange and Eduardo was
telling you how to position your mic and
you're like thank you Eduardo and then
that was it and then there was no bid
afterwards and then now the only gripe
you have with him is is music you told
people I was a vampire for like the
first two years that I knew you I
honestly thought you were that wasn't me
doing it I honestly thought that you
drank the blood of the living that you
slept mostly during the day that you had
to be covered in the native soil of
Armenia okay before uh these were things
I I thought true well we've moved on
from that but my thing is your whole
thing with now with Eduardo is that just
he plays music you don't like I mean no
I think it's I'm so angry well first of
all Eduardo is very accomplished at what
he does yes and uh does a very good job
you famously uh and you've written a
book about how you're terrible what you
do I think it's called world's worst
assistant that was your title not mine
by son of mosesian I appreciate the plug
but this you you need a better you need
you need to [ __ ] on Eduardo yeah I don't
think it's time I'm upset no no not on
all of us you [ __ ] on Adam you [ __ ] on
blay you [ __ ] on Matt yeah I'm just
gonna be I'm gonna be really honest with
you Eduardo is very knowledgeable he's
very skilled he's good looking fella uh
I come in here he's just killing it day
in day out and so other than him playing
music loudly whenever I come into the
studio which you know isn't my favorite
thing I have no gripe with Eduardo
Eduardo is we're lucky to have him I
can't say that about you
but you don't need grapes you don't need
to make fun of his Tweed and make fun of
Adam with his uh Rolls-Royce and you
just make fun of play just a general I
mean Matt Gauley is a legitimately
comical character you know he comes in
here you are you have your stuff that
you just bought on eBay
you're just a Hanes t-shirt right right
you dress defensively now because the
first couple of times you showed up when
I first met him he was wearing a
Sherlock Holmes deer Stalker Cat that he
got on Etsy
it's true why are you laughing
do you want to do this he smokes a kooky
pipe he's kind of us against each other
do you see that no but you see that you
but anyway
Eduardo is just what are you gonna say
back me up on this you shut up you
[ __ ]
you know what I love you just read that
swear awful little card you wrote
Because you've been practicing that to
seem less girly
yeah stupid Scrooge you're a big fuzzle
dick
he just can't do it he can't do it
energy from soda right as somebody who
has two older sisters yeah I have one
specifically who would always tell my
mom or dad hey why are you yelling at me
yeah yell at him but see anyone
listening right now is like man I could
listen to Eduardo all day you know and
we've done studies that show that so no
when you start talking people turn the
radio way down just because of the
volume the radio
[Music]
when people listen to this they gather
around the philco and they've come in
and they're wearing their bib overalls
okay because they've been toiling all
dust in the field and it's time to
listen to the Conor O'Brien podcast
okay here now this program brought to
you by corn cob cookies
let's go so angry oh my God all right
well anyway you're the best Eduardo
sounds beautiful because of you thank
you nicely done no you don't even listen
I can't listen to this crap
I got things to do absolutely [ __ ]